.
THE UKRAINIANS DEFINITELY NOT
SAYING IT WAS THEM SO FAR.
>> ALL RIGHT.
FRED PLEITGEN, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
WE WILL CHECK BACK.
>> UKRAINIANS ARE ALREADY
CHEERING THE CRIMEAN BRIDGE
EXPLOSION EVEN WITHOUT CLAIMING
RESPONSIBILITY.
ONE SENIOR UKRAINIAN OFFICIAL
POSTING THIS ON TWITTER.
MARILYN MONROE'S FAMOUS BIRTHDAY
SERENADE TO JFK.
♪ HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO YOU ♪
♪
>> AND THIS IS WHY.
THE EXPLOSION OF THE KERCH
BRIDGE COMING HOURS AFTER
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S 70th BIRTHDAY.
IN KYIV UKRAINIANS TOOK SELFIES
IN FRONT OF A PAINTING OF THE
BRIDGE BLAST.
FOR MORE, LET'S TURN TO MILITARY
ANALYST RETIRED AIR FORCE
COLONEL CEDRIC LEIGHTON.
COLONEL, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
FRED PLEITGEN USED THE WORD
HUMILIATING, THIS WOULD BE
HUMILIATING TO PUTIN.
HOW DO YOU SEE IT?
>> DEFINITELY.
THIS IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
HUMILIATIONS THAT PUTIN COULD
EXPERIENCE, LET ALONE SOMETHING
HAPPEN IN MOSCOW.
THIS SITUATION WITH THE KERCH
BRIDGE BEING BLOWN UP SEEN AS A
MAJOR ENGINEERING PROJECT OF THE
RUSSIAN FEDERATION BEING
DISRUPTED AND AT LEAST PART OF
IT DESTROYED.
SO THIS IS A BIG BLOW TO THE
PRESTIGE OF RUSSIA AND
ESPECIALLY TO PUTIN'S PERSONAL
PRESTIGE.
>> HE PERSONALLY WAS ON THAT
BRIDGE CELEBRATING THAT IT WAS
PUT THERE BACK IN 2018, AND SO
NOW DESCRIBE FOR US HOW VITAL
THIS BRIDGE IS IN MOVING
SUPPLIES AS PART OF THE MILITARY
STRATEGY FOR PUTIN AND HOW THIS
WOULD BE A BIG DISRUPTOR.
>> SO THIS BRIDGE ONLY HAS ROAD
LINKS, BUT ALSO AS FRED PLEITGEN
MENTIONED A RAIL LINK, AND THE
WAY THIS WORKS IS THAT THE
RUSSIANS CAN MOVE A LOT OF THEIR
TANKS, A LOT OF THEIR ARMORED
PERSONNEL EQUIPMENT, ALL OF THE
MISSILES THAT THEY HAVE
STATIONED IN CRIMEA.
A LOT OF THEM THEY CAN MOVE OVER
THIS BRIDGE BY RAIL OR BY ROAD.
THE FACT THAT THIS IS DISRUPTED
FORCES THEM TO USE SEABORNE
SUPPLY ROUTES INTO CRIMEA,
EITHER FROM RUSSIA DIRECTLY
THROUGH THE SEA OR THEY CAN DO
IT AROUND EUROPE THROUGH THE
MEDITERRANEAN AND EVENTUALLY
INTO THE BLACK SEA.
SO THIS REALLY PUTS A REAL
DIFFICULTY ON THE RUSSIANS IN
TERMS OF THEIR LOGISTICS EFFORT,
WHICH ALREADY HAS HAD A LOT OF
CHALLENGES.
SO ONCE YOU DISRUPT A MAJOR RAIL
AND ROAD LINE LIKE THIS, YOU
FORCE THEM TO GO ON ALTERNATIVE
ROUTES AND SOME OF THOSE ROUTES
ARE NOT AS GOOD, NOT AS BROAD,
NOT AS MODERN AS WHAT THE KERCH
BRIDGE WAS.
>> OBVIOUSLY, THIS WILL FURTHER
AGITATE PUTIN.
SO WHAT DO YOU EXPECT HIS
RESPONSE MIGHT BE?
>> SO I EXPECT HIM TO ACTUALLY
GO AFTER MORE CIVILIAN TARGETS
IN UKRAINE.
KIND OF WHAT WE SAW IN THE LAST
FEW DAYS WITH THE RECENT ROCKET
ATTACKS ON PLACES NEAR KYIV AND
THEN OF COURSE MORE RECENTLY
AROUND ZAPORIZHZHIA.
THAT IS THE KIND OF THING THAT I
EXPECT HIM TO DO.
HE WOULD TRY, IF HE COULD DO IT,
TO MOUNT SOME MORE MILITARY
OPERATIONS THAT POTENTIALLY HE
WILL TRY TO GO AFTER THE PEOPLE
THAT HE THINKS ARE DIRECTLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS.
THAT MIGHT BE A HARDER THING FOR
HIM TO DO, BUT IT'S CERTAINLY ON
HIS TARGET LIST.
I'M CERTAIN OF IT.
>> AND THEN WE ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT RUSSIA'S DEFENSE MINISTER
APPOINTED A NEW COMMANDER FOR
OPERATIONS IN UKRAINE.
OF COURSE, THIS COMES AS
UKRAINIAN FORCES HAVE LIBERATED
NEARLY 1,000 SQUARE MILES IN ITS
LATEST OFFENSIVE.
HOW CRITICAL IS THIS MOMENT?
>> WELL, IT DEPENDS ON THE NEW
COMMANDER.
IT'S VERY INTERESTING WHEN THEY
TRY TO SHUFFLE THE DECKS, IF YOU
WILL, ON THIS PARTICULAR
MILITARY HIERARCHY.
IT SEEMS AS IF A LOT OF THE
PEOPLE THAT THEY PUT IN THESE
POSITIONS HAVE NOT SUCCEEDED.
THE PREDECESSOR WAS A GENERAL
WHO WAS KNOWN FOR HIS WORK IN
SYRIA AND BEFORE THAT CHECHNYA.
SO THEY COME WITH REPUTATIONS.
THE PROBLEM THAT THEY ARE
RUNNING INTO IS THAT THEIR
TALENT POOL IS NOT AS DEEP AS
THEY WOULD LIKE IT TO BE AND AS
WE THOUGHT IT WAS.
SO THEY HAVE NOT ONLY A LACK OF
TALENT IN THEIR GENERALS, BUT
THEY ALSO HAVE A LACK OF
FOLLOW-THROUGH.
THEY CAN'T REALLY, EVEN IF THEY
HAVE A VERY CAPABLE GENERAL,
SAY, IN THE MODE OF AN
EISENHOWER OR THE RUSSIAN
CONTEXT, THESE PEOPLE HAVE A
MUCH MORE DIFFICULT TIME HAVING
THEIR ORDERS CARRIED OUT THAN
WAS THE CASE IN WORLD WAR II.
AND IT'S A VERY DIFFERENT
ENVIRONMENT FOR THE RUSSIANS.
PEOPLE ARE NOT WILLING TO FOLLOW
THESE ORDERS.
YOU ARE SEEING THEM VOTE WITH
THEIR FEET, IN ESSENCE, BY
MOVING INTO PLACES LIKE
KAZAKHSTAN AND FINLAND TO ESCAPE
THE DRAFT.
TO THESE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
PEOPLE ARE DOING.
THE SAME THING IS WITHIN THE
RUSSIAN MILITARY CONTEXT, EVEN
IF THEY ARE RECRUITED INTO IT,
THEY FIND IT, YOU KNOW, REALLY
POSSIBLE FOR THEM TO AVOID
CARRYING OUT A LOT OF ORDERS,
AND THAT IS, OF COURSE, PLAYING
IN